i am very excited to be here um this is
delicious salad
i'm so excited watermelon is truly one
of my favorite ingredients
so teach me a ton all right so let's do
it so we're gonna start with a very
simple and easy kind of vinaigrette over
here
so we're going to take our lemon juice
in here we're going to add in also some
orange juice and now we're also going to
use the zest of both i am a big zest
person i love zest
i can never get enough zest never enough
so we are going to i have a zest for
life
love that so we are just going to get in
a bunch of our zest in there
both the orange zest and the lemon zest
in there and that's just gonna add more
kind of aromas and smells when you're
doing that it is
kind of like the little secret
ingredient to just kind of really boost
the flavor
then followed by that we're going to add
in some balsamic vinegar are you do you
like vinegar
um i love vinegar but i always want it
to be
in the back seat and the olive oil to be
the driver
good call i like acid coming from fruit
more honestly same that's why i do like
kind of the two acids from fruit and
the balsamic then we add a little bit of
olive oil into there as well
and of course some salt and pepper
always important any restaurant food you
eat
one of the main reasons it's more
delicious than home food is they they
just
use way more salt and pepper than anyone
would realize um now we're going to
whisk
that up over here and now a little trick
i do
is i'm actually going to add our
watermelon into the vinaigrette before
we add the arugula so kind of soak some
of it up so we're going to toss it in
here and then as you can see the
watermelon's going to almost kind of
soak
up all that vinegar and all the lemon
juice and the zest
then i like to add in the arugula but
it's very important if you're
entertaining with this you really want
to
do this right before because the
balsamic vinegar has a dark color and it
will kind of just ruin the color
if you do it too far in advance that's a
hot tip hot tip that's what you wanted
to do hot tip
so now also very important salads i
always love to add in some type of nut
it gives it like a nuttiness a little
crunch so let's add in some walnuts
and kind of like that fattiness yeah you
really need the fattiness now let's toss
that together
and finally let's add well now finally
we have two more ingredients
we're going to add second to last second
if it's the last correct we're going to
add in our arugula which is personally
my favorite
um of all the greens because it's really
nice and peppery it adds so much great
flavor
i love it also um with melted cheese and
a sandwich i'm just going to say that
speaking of cheese we also have some
crumbled up
feta which will give us even more
fattiness some salt is really important
i think feta is
a great cheese to go with in any type of
salad it's also sturdy it really holds
itself up
so now just toss that together and drew
uh that is it if you're entertaining it
is a
very quick recipe to make to improve and
press your guests we did this
in like three minutes now i know that
you're supposed to serve it in a little
bowl but
we're eating from these i'm getting good
i love beans yeah i'm taking this back
in my dressing okay good
perfect
oh my gosh mm-hmm
no that was so good i don't think either
of us
just uttered the word of english but we
knew exactly what each other meant
you can hear masticating and delight
and that's as far as i'm concerned all
that matters
i absolutely god when you hit that feta
right the fattiness of saltiness and i
always look forward to being with you
and i am so
lucky to be a culinary contributor with
you or you're the culinary contributor
and i'm
your little subject thank you eton
bernath go to the drewberrymore show.com
for the full recipe and get your summer
[Music]
on